aren't as many long range interactions from a cubit on one side of the chip to another on the other side of the chip
which we know is very error prone so this is really good for the hardware that we have available today next is
this topic even of Interest well I hop I have already sort of convinced you that yes high energy physics is of great
interest people were willing to spend billions of dollars to build the LHC and thousands of scientists and and
technicians across the globe have dedicated their lives to this field that's how important it is but the
shringer model is simplistic and isn't designed to cover three spatial Dimensions nevertheless it is an
important model as it still provides currently testable slices and useful simplification of a full
Theory last how was this work done or what approach would they use if they were looking to continue the work in
simulation type experiments vqe is one of the most common approaches and is the first step is almost always the same
prepare the ground state in this case it is a vacuum State and in this experiment they use a new version a vqe called SC
adapt vqe to prepare both the ground state and the hron wave packet on top of the vacuum the next step is to then
allow the hadrons to evolve or propagate in time lastly we need to identify the
observables that we want to detect now if those steps sounded kind of familiar to you minus the Hadron wave
packet part that's because these steps are very similar to what we covered in the qaoa example in the previous episode
hopefully you're starting to see some patterns emerging here the components needed for vqe are very similar to qaoa
we start in a familiar State here the vacuum State and then we let it evolve in time with a series of exponentiated
hamiltonians divided into manageable chunks where n is the number of Divisions the only big difference here
is we create the wave packet of hadron centered within our circuit before we start letting it evolve so how is this
done well the vacuum state is the ground state and we've already sort of covered how to map this now preparing the Hadron
wave packet is a bit different on this vacuum a hadron can be exciting by creating a firon anti- fermon pair on
adjacent sites by preparing a superposition of such hadrons at different locations an arbitrary wave
packet can be prepared the authors centered their wave packet in the middle of the circuit to observe the evolution
without exceeding a boundary but remember the name of the game when working with noisy qpu is to keep the
circuit depth manageable to do this the SC adapt vqe protocol uses symmetry and
hierarchies in length scales to determine low depth Quantum circuits for State preparation the idea is that this
will create an onzo with a smaller number of parameters equating to a shallower depth more details can of
course be found in the paper than we have time to cover here so make sure to check it out now let's take a look at the results this experiment was run on
an IBM Quantum Heron device and implemented a few different types of airor mitigation and supression
including a more recent technique called operator decoherence renormalization as well as dynamical de coupling zero noise
extrapolation and poly twirling now let's try to interpret the data the observable that we're actually going to
be measuring to observe how the wave packet propagates is something called the chyal condensate which is a bit
abstract but it's basically a superf fluid phase of the hadrons now we can see the wave packet centered here on the
sites that have been designated to run this experiment where the color corresponds to the chyro condensate the
left side shows the airfree results from the simulator while the right side shows the results from the IBM quantum
computer Torino ideally these would be mirror images of one another due to symmetry so you can see that there are
some imperfections now this vertical y AIS corresponds to the chunks of time I
measured earlier so why don't we take some horizontal cuts through the first and last time steps of the data to see
what happens to the wave packet at Time tals 1 here in Orange corresponding to
this cut you can see that the caral condensate is narrow and localized it it also corresponds really well to the
simulation that was done for comparison at tal 14 however though it is much more spread out and is less
localized maybe the comparison to the simulator isn't quite as perfect now but you can still obviously see very good agreement between Theory and the data
which is encouraging in conclusion this is a very cool example of the type of simulation work you might not initially think about
applying quantum computers to however in fact you can and it works it's not perfect but you don't have to be a
particle physics expert to see that the quantum computer accuracy predicts the outward propagation of the wave packet
which is exactly what we would expect to find hopefully future work in this area will continue and high energy physicists
will continue to find ways to incorporate Quantum Computing into their work streams the aim is to solve theoretical problems more precisely and
those which can't be done classically and use experiments to accept or reject theories in hopes of discovering new
physics building improved detectors and leading to a better understanding of nature at its most fundamental
level our next example focuses on optimization and will be a deep dive into a paper called biased field
digitized counter adiabatic Quantum optimization which was done by members of the kipu quantum team in the
University of the bass country in Spain we'll begin like we did before
with a series of definitions the first is counter adiabatic which is a type of evolution that suppresses non-adiabatic
effects experienced by a system regardless of how fast those processes occur recall the adiabatic theorem from
the last episode you usually need to let a system evolve very slowly if you wish for it to remain in the ground state
this is a big problem because the slower we have to let things evolve the more time we have for errors to
occur counter adiabatic driving often abbreviated as CD aims to combat this by
adding terms that counteract these unwanted excitations the main idea here is to speed up the whole experiment and
reduce edce Quantum circuit depth by suppressing excitations that could lead to spous
Transitions now let's talk about what a bias field is other iterative algorithms like vqe take classical parameters into
these states and use classical optimizers to search the many dimensional parameter space for that set
that yields a minimum expectation value for a fixed hamiltonian in this case they instead vary the hamiltonian each